imagine you had a nightmare where you
had to relive your
adolescence my memories shine almost
like a diamond but not because I love
them because I hate
[Music]
them when I was a teenager I would
imagine myself falling in love I love
him I love him I love for all my crushes
I was trying to beat what ever they
wanted me to be I was always just acting
roll please oh hi to uh who's this oh
um I think of these Recreations as like
an emotional exorcism are you lost I sit
there I am truly haunted by these
things and one of the things that I
can't get past is why they still bother
me the the guy organizing the reunion
posted this dress Winter Park this is
like blood red I'm going to kill them
all resentment red resentment red oh God
the country club I just feel like this
is a huge
mistake don't make me going in
there I can understand being traumatized
but why you continue all these years
later to allow them to have all this
power over you blows my mind why would I
remember this for 25 years years if I
didn't know then that it was that bad
the Paradox of going back is to have to
succumb once again to that sense of
yourself as totally
inconsequential so why on Earth would I
go
back